[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to our
program i'd like to know
i am accompanied by the distinguished
friend
c.a murray and we're glad that he's back
from panama
after a long ordeal
and i think every day that goes by
you're a little more rested up from the
two-day journey
up here and it's always good to have you
here ca
good to be here good to be here i was
wondering when where you were going with
that
distinguished
but it's good to be here and always good
to study the word of god with you
amen if you want to send us your
questions you can do so at the address
that you'll see on the screen
tv at some tv.org tv at some tv.org
send us your questions we have a big
pile of questions because this program
lasts half an hour once a week
we're probably going to have to expand
that but you know we answer them
as quickly as possible so keep tuning in
i want to ask ca to please have a word
of prayer
and then i'm going to throw a question
at you
and i know that you're going to be able
to answer let's pray
father god we praise you and thank you
for this opportunity
to open the word of god we also know
that
spiritual things are spiritually
discerned so we would ask
lord for the mind of christ we would ask
for the presence and power of your holy
spirit
as we seek to mine from your word
truths that are important for the
spiritual life of your people
bless us just now we do pray and we
thank you in advance
in jesus name amen amen you know i just
want to make one point clear and that is
that
ca and i do not get our heads together
in preparation to answer these questions
we own we do our own research
and it's amazing how we're always on the
same page
praise the lord because the bible has
one message
uh here we have an interesting question
ca i don't think anybody's ever asked
this question
at least as far as i know we were
debating
on this issue whereby others were saying
the tithing was done
in the sanctuary meaning to say that the
sanctuary is christ jesus himself
so no need to pay tithe and they
continue to say
that even jesus himself never paid tithe
because he symbolized himself with the
levites
so i would like to know through your
explanations so that i may also explain
to them so the gist of the question is
did jesus pay tithe and his jesus is the
same
the sanctuary so we don't have to return
the tithe
you know and i want to say this
respectfully
um you really got to do a bit of
dancing to try to come to try to twist
this to make it
to make it fit you know you got to be a
pretty good
jitterbug to kind of you know
sometimes when you're when you when you
don't want to do the will of god
when you don't want to follow in a way
that is
fairly plainly explained in the word of
god you've got to
do some twisting and turning and
cavorting uh
to try to make something fit you know
um so let's let's try to work it
out as best we can okay um i i think
we we know and understand that tithe of
course is one tenth of our increase
and it is old testament affirmed it is
new testament affirmed
that uh god's people ought to pay tithe
um this idea of jesus
being the sanctuary and so
you don't have to pay tithe
just is not logical to me it just
doesn't fit for me
and and does not work for me um
christ himself said render unto caesar
caesar's things
render unto god god's things and and
tithes
is one of those things that belongs to
god
it's it's not our money it's his money
to use it is to steal from god
shall a man rob god but you have robbed
me in tithes and offerings
so i think we need to establish
at basis that um
the the the command to to give god that
which belongs to him
is old testament his new testament is
incumbent upon the christian
even today amen you know there's an
interesting verse that probably most are
acquainted with in luke chapter 9
oh yes and verse 58 um
of course here jesus is speaking to
judas the text of does not explicitly
say so but
we know from the spirit of prophecy that
jesus was talking of judas
who had offered his services and jesus
said to him foxes have holes and birds
of the air
have nests but the son of man has
nowhere to lay his head well if he
didn't have any income he
you wouldn't have to tithe would he
good point although although we don't
know
whether he tied or not we do know that
he did pay the tribute money
yes you know let's notice uh uh luke 17
verse 27
so if jesus paid the tribute money
would we not expect him if he had income
to pay the tithe as well
it doesn't say that he didn't pay tithe
that's an assumption that the
person is making yes so what does luke
17 verse 27 say
uh 1727.
we go 17 27
maybe that's not the verse after all
uh-uh it's where it's where jesus sent
peter
to get the money out of the fishes on
the fish's mouth
yeah persistent widow
i thought i thought it was in luke 17
but
evidently i wrote down the wrong
reference but anyway i think probably
most people are acquainted
with uh you know the accusation that was
launched against jesus
yes that he didn't pay his taxes and so
uh you know jesus said to peter you know
let's let's keep caesar happy
go uh go and the first fish that you you
bring out
open his mouth and the tax money is
going to be in it
[Laughter]
well if if jesus paid respect to
civil government you know he paid
respect to the government of god well
sure so if he had tithe to pay
i think we would not do violence to the
text or to the word of god
in assuming that he was uh he followed
through and this all in this also
um so that he he gave to god what what
was
was necessary certainly there is no
statement that he did not do so
so we assume that he did because he did
all things right sure
uh well anyway i want to i want us to
look up also
first corinthians 9 verses 3 to 14. if
you could look up those verses
uh first corinthians 9 verses 3 to 14.
first corinthians and we're at verse
chapter 9. the way that reference is
matthew 17 and verse 27
i kind of figured i got the wrong gospel
so
you know the it says they're
nevertheless lest we offend them
go to the sea cast in a hook and take
the fish that comes up first
and when you have opened its mouth you
will find a piece of money
take that and give it to them for me and
you
so jesus paid taxes to caesar so
obviously he must have paid tithe to god
if he had any income which
foxes have holes and birds have nests
jesus didn't have anything to lean on
okay so anyway back to first corinthians
9 this passage proves
ca that the tithing system is still in
force
after jesus says ascended to heaven
indeed uh so let's uh if you want to
read beginning with verse three
verse three so in first corinthians nine
verse three my defense
to those who examine me is this
do we have no right to eat and drink
do we have no right to take along a
believing wife
as do also the other apostles the
brothers
of the lord and cephas or is it only
barnabas and i who have no right to
refrain
from working okay so some people were
criticizing
paul and the apostles for traveling yes
and
and for receiving remuneration for it
uh let's continue with verse seven
whoever goes to the war at his own
expense
who plants a vineyard and does not eat
eat its eat of its fruit or who tends a
flock
and does not drink of the milk of the
do i say these things as a mere man
or does not the law say the same also
for it is written in the law of moses
you shall not
muzzle an ox while it treads out the
grain
is it oxen is it oxen god
is concerned about it so let's just stop
there a minute why why does this
why does paul include this text from the
old testament not to muzzle the ox
when he's trading the grain because the
ox is working
yes and the work worker is worthy of his
higher earth is higher
the worker and and the point that paul
is going to make is that he who works in
the gospel
deserves to be remunerated with the
tithe yes so let's continue reading at
verse
10. or does he say
it all together for our sakes for our
sakes
no doubt it this is written that he who
plows
should plow in hope and he who threshes
in hope
should be partaker of his hope
okay continue if we have sown spiritual
things for you
is it a great thing if we reap your
material
things see there there's the if if we
serve the lord in spiritual things
we have a right to be sustained in
materials in material things
okay verse 12. if others are partakers
of this right over you
are we not even more
nevertheless we have not used this right
but endure all things lest we hinder the
gospel
of christ now now come the two key
verses
13 and 14 where paul is going to compare
their right his right and those his
fellow
laborers their right to be remunerated
as the levites
and the priests were in the hebrew
sanctuary so let's read verse 13 and 14.
do you not know that those who minister
the holy things eat of the things
of the temple and those who serve at the
altar
partake of the offerings of the altar
and verse 14 even so the lord has
commanded
that those who preach the gospel should
live
from the gospel it can't be any clearer
that the tithing system
for those who are preaching the gospel
is still
functioning long after jesus went to
heaven
and he's using the example of the
levites which this person brings up
in this question you know when you when
you read
first and second corinthians you've got
to remember
uh the corinthian churches were
churches that were in trouble and you
can't paint with two broader brush but
most of the the council to the
corinthian church is corrective
because they were always getting it
wrong um so
when he's talking to them he's trying to
straighten out a problem
that exists uh this is not being done
right
you need to do it this way and and that
is particularly important when you're
talking about things like tongues and
speaking in tongues and
other kinds of things that he's not
praising that stuff he's trying to
root that stuff out right uh so here is
the same thing
um those who who who are preaching who
are living
who are teaching who are traveling uh
they have to be paid from the tithe
right and he uses the old testament
pattern as his basis for argument here
you know maybe i can just digress a
little bit
you know some people take what
corinthians
says and they take it as if the apostle
paul believed
what they believed precisely let me just
give you an example here
in first corinthians chapter 15
first corinthians chapter 15
where the apostle paul says if there is
no resurrection of the dead why do you
baptize for the dead
and so they say see the the mormons for
example say see it's okay to baptize for
the dead
but the apostle paul hears his he's
saying if there isn't any resurrection
of the dead why is it that you are doing
this
he's not saying that that's what you're
supposed to do and you're doing it
correct he's correcting a problem he's
correcting a problem just like all of
the other problems
in corinth yes and i think that that's
what you're referring to
uh you know when when it comes to this
passage in first corinthians chapter 9
where they were saying oh you know just
let
the apostles when they're preaching the
gospel let them work yeah for a living
you know but those who preach the gospel
are to live from the gospel
so so i think i hope that that helps in
answering the question
we have another question here and this
one will take us the better part of
what we have the time we have remaining
i'd like to know about bible
translations
can anyone provide any pointers about
selecting one
can you all tell me about comparing them
so what can we say about bible versions
of which there
are a plethora yes well
one of the things i think we need to to
do starting out is
sort of spend just a moment or two on a
translation as opposed to a paraphrase
and because when you when you
are dealing with the word of god
you want to be as as accurate as you
possibly can
so you want to use a translation as
opposed to a paraphrase
which is a a person will take a
a portion of the bible and then give a
summation of it
and it's good you've got you've got
paraphrases uh they read well and
they're they're easy to kind of they're
very inspirational but you don't want to
necessarily use that
for study right uh if if you're really
trying to understand
uh what's being said you want to get as
close
to the original as you possibly can and
you want the words to come at you not
just the thoughts
of a person who is sort of digesting
what is there
um oh let me let me let you speak i was
just going to mention that
you know if you have basically two
different groups of people
in the adventist church today you have
those who are king james
only and they are
critical usually of those who uh
even use the new king james version
because
you know the new king james version
makes some changes
you know i don't think that they're a
matter of life and death
but there's distinctions and differences
and
so what can we say about uh bible
versions as far as
which one we should use yes for me and
and i know you do this too when
when i'm doing bible study particularly
if i'm going to be teaching something
i pull out several um i i have king
james
i have new king james i have and i love
i've got civil rights as
as do you um you want to
stick with um something that you can
understand
that is readable um
you don't want to use a a catholic bible
or a bible that has changed the
commandments or done some things like
that
so you want to sort of stay away from
that but
for me for study use several
good translations and uh and begin with
that
the interesting thing is that many
people uh
say that uh the manuscripts that were
used for the king james version are
better manuscripts
than the western text type that were
used like for example the niv
or the new american standard bible etc
you have two groups of manuscripts that
stand behind
the king james and behind the other
bible versions very true
and so you know there's uh and and i
love the king james you know for
memorizing
yeah uh you know most of the texts that
i have memorized are from the king james
same with me
from the time that i was a child and
it's a good version but
it has some archaic terms and it also
has some difficult
syntax yes to follow because it's
written in
you know king james english yes and and
so
people wonder why i use the new king
james they say why does pastor boy
use the new king james version that's
one of the adulterated
versions of the bible but the main
reason why i use the king james
the new king james is because it doesn't
use the archaic terms it doesn't say the
and thou
and it doesn't have the tortuous syntax
it doesn't use words like you know
those who are alive and remain shall not
prevent those who are
are asleep yes you know prevent today
means to keep back
prevent back then means to proceed to
proceed so there's lots of archaic words
that have different meanings today than
there were back there
yeah so i use the new king james because
it's more readable
and when the new king james doesn't
square with
because i always like to look at the
original yes when it doesn't square with
the original
then uh when i read from the new king
james
i correct i say you know this is not the
correct reading
you know you really should read it in
this certain way
language is dynamic uh the king james is
several hundred years old language has
changed in that time
yes uh words like pear adventure when's
the last time you heard that using
conversation
you know
yeah we just we just language changes
and and
i've heard people say you know well if
it's good enough for christ is good
enough for me
no christ didn't speak king james
english
so so it's it's it's uh we we need to
sort of keep up with and
and then if you're introducing someone
to the bible
um and you you're trying to get them to
read king james english can be a little
work
trying to get through new king james a
little smoother a little easier to read
little better to understand
another archaic word uh or has a
different meaning now
is the word conversation the king james
uses the word conversation
and we we use that to say we're
conversing conversing
but really in uh that time conversation
meant conduct
or behavior mm-hmm very true and so true
and so if you're reading the king james
and you're not aware you say oh this is
talking about
conversing or talking it's not talking
about that it's talking about conduct
so so rather than having to explain the
sim
syntax over and over again and using
archaic terms and everything
it's much easier to use the king james
and when the king james digresses
from the nuclear from the meaning of the
original text
uh and when we say original text
obviously we don't have the autographs
we have copies of copies but when they
when it doesn't agree with uh
with the text with the different
manuscripts then you simply make an
explanation when you're reading the text
that
it's not translated correctly yeah and
then
when you're studying the word of god you
don't want to necessarily go for speed
you want to go for depth and
understanding
so if you run into something that seems
a little off i'll use that terminology
then pull out another translation or if
you are really adventurous grab your
concordance and do a little greek work
uh it's exciting right uh and it it
gives you
first of all gives you something to talk
about it gives you an understanding
of what is actually happening and you
can see the growth of words and
and terms and meanings and uh frankly i
love to do that i'll get stuck on a word
and stay there you know
and i know you will also get you kind of
just dig into it
and it's exciting to find out where it's
coming from yeah you know you take for
example john 5 39
ellen white actually used it in in both
ways
uh it appears in the king james in one
way and it appears in other versions in
another way
uh john 5 and verse 39 um
jesus says and this is the new king
james
he's speaking to the to the jews you
search the scriptures
for in them you think have you you have
eternal life and these are they which
testify of me
of me but if you look at the king james
the king james says search the
scriptures
so what is the correct translation you
search the scriptures or search the
scriptures
well the bottom line is that in greek
the imperative
and the indicative are the same word
so you have to allow the context to
dictate what is the correct translation
and ellen white uses both translations
because both are true
he's really saying to them you search
the scriptures because you think that
you have eternal life
they testify of me and you don't want to
come to me when you look at the context
yes
but it's also true that we should search
the scriptures right yes
yes so so either way either translation
is true and works out yeah
that's that's pretty neat
[Laughter]
and there are many examples like that in
the writings of ellen white
yes um well i don't know what more we
can say about this i'm sure that
some of those who are watching probably
will not agree with us
you know when i say that i use many
different versions and i'm sure that you
feel the same way
it's not because i'm endorsing those
versions you know i use the niv once in
a while
because it's better on the state of the
dead as far as i'm concerned
uh does that mean that i'm endorsing
everything in the niv
absolutely not because there are some
passages that the niv eliminates
from scripture very true and there's
some words that are
mistranslated if you look at the
original
so people need to understand that when i
use the niv or the new american standard
bible or the english standard version
i'm using them
because i've checked on the original
language and
the original language does square with
uh with the translation that is provided
by these more modern versions
yes but it doesn't mean that i'm
endorsing hook line and sinker
everything that is found in that
particular version i guess you could say
that i'm eclectic
in my handling and bible versions
very well fit let me say this my pastor
my friend
um while we've got a little time put in
a little commercial
for your new series on uh difficult text
on the state of the dead
i have been watching that yay from
panama well done
very very well done um i've been it's
been a part of my regular sabbath
afternoon
uh activity and uh very very well done
i know it comes on sabbath afternoon
after worship
because that's when i catch it it may
come on some other times but it is
well worth it and well worth done and
that is a series that uh
our our viewers may want to buy because
that's good stuff
well really well done thanks for the
commercial yeah appreciate it
okay now let's go to we have time for
one more question this one can be
answered quite simply
um i would show this verse to people
regarding homosexuality drug use
adultery and fornication etc
referring to first corinthians 6 9. the
particular part of the verse that i am
that i am having an issue with is
what is the meaning of abusers of
themselves with mankind that's from the
king james version
after reading the new king james version
of the bible and getting to this verse
it replaces abusers of themselves with
mankind
with nor sodomites in other words
the new king james understands abusers
of themselves with mankind as a sodomite
yes
so the question is which version king
james or new king james
is interpreted correctly what does
abusers of themselves with mankind
mean so what what can we say about that
yeah it's funny i've got that whole
thing in red right here
in my in in my bible um
i think i think it means any homosexual
relationship um
male female you've got lgbtq
lmnop qrsd you know you've got you've
got so many
um a person who is involved
in an unnatural relationship uh
i think falls in that category yeah and
you know the interest
the greek word the original greek word
that is used there
is arsenal koitai which is composed of
two words
arsene which is male 1 and koitai which
means to have sex where they
get the word coitus for him and so
literally it means a male homosexual
homosexual or as the niv translates a
homosexual offender
so probably the best translation would
be homosexual
uh there in first first corinthians
chapter six and verse nine
um and some people try to explain it
away by saying you know it's just
abusive homosexual relationships that is
being condemned but
actually it is condemning homosexuality
yes yes as a practice it doesn't mean
that we hate homosexuals
no you know they have freedom of choice
we need to love everybody
but that doesn't mean that we agree with
the behavior which the bible openly
condemns
yes yes you know in these last days um
there's so many things that were once
kept kind of in the closet
kept secret that are not kept secret
anymore everything's out
and you've got to preach against them
you've got to you've got to you you've
got to preach
the word of god right amen and the word
of god cuts across
some of the things that we like to do
amen and
it is unapologetic that's right yeah
well time is up
thank you for joining us today for i'd
like to know hope to see you next time
send us your questions god bless
[Music]
you